12 31 and the english and welsh are
fighting again
so wales has been sort of glossed over
in this series and there are two main
reasons
the first is that welsh politics is
extremely complicated and difficult to
explain the second reason is that welsh
words are nigh on impossible to
pronounce
so prior to 1231 england and its rulers
had always had an interest in its
western neighbour
after the norman conquest several lords
the lords of chester hereford and
shrewsbury collectively known as the
marcher lords were given a free hand to
conquer as much as they could
importantly these lordships were
essentially mini kingdoms whereby the
lords were fairly free from royal
interference
at first these march lords made good
progress but the terrain being mostly
mountainous in the north made complete
conquest costly and so progress stopped
if there were any instability in england
such as that of the anarchy or the
barons ward the welsh would often rise
up and retake the lands that they had
earlier been deprived of
as you can imagine this slowed down
conquest by quite a bit and
by quite a bit i mean over 200 years so
by 1231 the english controlled these
lands and the numerous welsh princes and
lords controlled this
whales throughout its history had always
been fragmented to varying degrees and
so the idea of welshness was based upon
things like language and importantly
not being english the three major realms
in wares were gwyneth palace and
dehoibath all of whom had their puppets
and alliance systems in place
the balance of power between and the
size of these realms very hugely over
the decades and wales was often in flux
the greatest of the worst princes in
1231 was llewellyn the great who was
both a capable general and a skilled
negotiator clewellen and his domain of
gwyneth had been the dominant power in
worlds for over 30 years
at this point he was mostly concerned
with the succession in keeping gwyneth
together with all its vassals intact
the culture of wales was also very
distinctive from that of its
anglo-french neighbours
it was a culture which honored the
marshal that is the military and the
heroic
princes and rulers were praised for
their warrior virtues and welsh law
stated that princes were entitled to a
set percentage of the loot they took
from those they defeated
these welsh princes and domains should
not be seen as undeveloped societies
since they had very complex systems of
government
much like the english the welsh could
and did build castles which indicates a
strong ability to command resources and
men
of course in comparison to england the
amount of resources a man powered the
welsh could come on was significantly
smaller
so in 1240 hiluelan died he left his two
sons the half-brothers griffith and
aphid as heirs
llewelyn had previously appealed to the
english king henry iii to have his
second son daphith
accepted as heir henry said yes so
daffith inherited the kingdom and
immediately afterwards through his
half-brother in prison along with his
nephew who was also called llewellyn
one of the conditions of his accession
was that he wasn't allowed to keep his
father's vassals which daffith refused
and so
wore england having much more in terms
of resources won very quickly daffy
submitted gave up his vassals and handed
his half-brother over to henry who
quickly locked him in the tower of
london
this meant that if staff has played up
henry could simply install his brother
as the prince of gwyneth
griffith did not enjoy being king
henry's pawn and so tried to escape the
tower in 1244 and fell to his death
whilst doing so
this was unfortunate for henry but also
presumably griffith due to the whole
being dead thing
daffith used henry's bad luck to forge
an alliance with the welsh
principalities and raided english-held
lands
it was also about this time that daathis
began to use the title the prince of
wales
so raiding english held lands was
upsetting to the english king and so
war again henry invaded gwyneth and the
fighting didn't lead to much until
daafith died in 1246.
daffith had no heirs and so his two
nephews the previously locked up
llewelyn and another called a wayne
inherited gwyneth together
both approached king henry for peace and
recognition of their domain which he
granted in return for them ceding all of
this territory which they did
very little happened in wales over the
next decade barring the usual raiding by
both sides
so in 1255 another brother came of age
and king henry decided to give him some
of the land in gwyneth to further weaken
it clewellin said no and so civil war
broke out between the three brothers
clewellin was victorious and became the
sole ruler of gwyneth the next year king
henry had his son
edward placed in control of these lands
shockingly the english weren't very kind
to the conquered welsh and so some of
the native welsh lords appealed to
lewellen to invade
llewelyn successfully retook most of the
lost land and also began to style
himself as the prince of wales which
king henry did not like one bit
the english didn't meaningfully respond
to this invasion though that said after
henry had secured peace
with france in 1259 he was able to turn
his full attention to his neighbors well
at least he would have were it not for
the issues between him and his barons
which culminated in the second baron's
war breaking out in 1263.
during the second barons war the rebel
leader simon de montfort cut a deal with
llewellyn which saw de montfort
recognised llewellyn's place as the
prince of wales in return for a sack of
cash
this meant that as long as de montfort
was alive and in charge wales would be
secure
so the next year de montfort was killed
at the battle of eve sherman so
clewellin invaded the english-held lands
with his vassals to gain as much as
possible before henry iii could
consolidate his position
clewellin wasn't rebelling to make wales
an independent domain like scotland he
had always accepted the king of england
as his lord and understood the fact that
he held wales as a vassal
over the next two years he gained all of
this territory before asking king henry
iii to negotiate
these negotiations culminated in the
1267 treaty of montgomery
these allowed llewelyn to keep his
territories and henry iii acknowledged
his title as the prince of wales in
return for all of this llewellyn was to
pay a sack of cash
many of the lesser princes of wales had
an issue with this since none of them
were too happy to swear loyalty to
someone they didn't see as their
superior in 1272 king henry died and was
succeeded by his son edward edward
didn't return to england to 1274 since
he was on a crusade
upon his return he was crowned king
edward the first due to the fact that
there had been no king edwards before
this
none whatsoever the reason for this in
case you're wondering is that edward
traced his lineage back to william the
conqueror i.e the victor and not the
anglo-saxons i.e the losers
in 1275 edward demanded that llewellyn
come and pay him homage which he refused
edward wasn't going to put up with the
resistant vassal and so
war in 1277 edward's army crossed into
wales interestingly the majority of the
soldiers in edward's army were actually
welsh clewellin surrendered before any
major blood spilling occurred and the
english annexed all of this territory
the remaining territory was split
between clewellin who kept a much
smaller gwyneth and his brother daphith
who was given these lands
daff wasn't happy with the lands he had
been given by the king so naturally
revolt was the only answer
clewellen joined his brother with many
other prominent welsh nobles in trying
to remove the english this occurred in
1282 and edward's response was not one
of pacification but total conquest and
subjugation the combined forces of the
english crown in the north and the
marcher lords in the south meant that
the welsh could do little to resist
clewell was killed in later 1282 and his
brother succeeded him but ultimately
edward had crushed the revolt by
mid-1283 so in the end daffith was taken
prisoner and soon after executed ending
definitively the native rule of wales
the fate of wales was finalized in the
statute of written which gave these
areas to edward's lords and these areas
to edward personally
this statute marks the end of an
independent wales and barring a few
rebellions over the coming centuries
english rule there was fairly secure
it changed wales in several other ways
as well it carved winits up into
counties in the same way that england
was furthermore the statute also
proclaimed that the laws of england were
now the laws of wales
soon after the conquest had been
finished the english immediately began
to displace the native welsh by booting
them out of towns and offered the best
farmland
of course remaining in wales was
expensive due to the armies of
occupation and the building of many
castles which collectively were known as
the iron ring
the greatest of these castles was at the
new northern welsh capital of carnarvon
as a result edward had to come up with
inventive ways of raising money such as
taxing the sale of all and of course
taxing the jews
so according to english law all jews
were the property of the monarch and so
he could do with them whatever he saw
fit
this normally came in the form of taxing
them heavily but edward was desperate
for money so in 1290 he issued the edict
of expulsion
they spanned all jews from living in
england and wales in practice this meant
that the king could seize all of the
jewish property in england for himself
and importantly all money owed to the
jews was now owed to the crown
another means of raising money was via
taxes in order to raise the taxes
necessary edward had to regularly appeal
to his lords
the king and his lords would talk in
french palais at a place called a
parliament or in english a parliament
thus it can be said that the english
parliament found much of its roots in
the subjugation of the welsh
monarchs had called assemblies of their
nobles for many centuries sometimes for
advice but mostly to raise
money in men for wars edward's
parliament was an extension of the
earlier gatherings called by simon de
montfort but importantly edward was
expected to call upon his laws regularly
this new parliament was an intricate
part of the government of the realm
every year edward was expected to call
his laws to attend and settle the most
pressing affairs of state
in 1295 the people invited to these
parliaments were broadened beyond the
lords to include knights and other
representatives otherwise known as the
commons
edward also reissued magna carta again
in 1297 although he had done this a few
times before
in many respects magna carta was
changing from something that monarchs
would issue as a compromise to simply
being the accepted law of the land
in 1301 edward made another change to
the ruling of wales when he made his son
edward the prince of wales it was from
then that the title of prince of wales
became synonymous with the heir to the
throne six years after this edward the
first died and his son was crowned
edward ii
edward ii had a troubled relationship
with his parents mostly because of his
close relationship with a man called
piers gaviston whom edward made the earl
of cornwall upon his accession to the
throne
edward married the daughter of the king
of france isabella and whilst he was
away negotiating the terms of the
marriage he left gaviston in charge
this upset the other nobles who felt
that they were being shut out by
edward's favourite
in the end as a compromise gaviston was
exiled in fact several times
and after a disagreement with his barons
edward recalled him gaviston returned to
england but was captured soon after and
executed by edward's barons to make
matters worse for the king his armies
were being pushed out of scotland the
most famous event being the 1314 battle
of bannockburn
things got much better fred would after
this and by much better i mean there was
a major famine in 1315.
back in wales another revolt was started
by a man called loelyn brennan 1316 who
was rebelling against harsh rule
instead of heeding the king's summons
llewellyn revolted and captured the
castle at care philly
ultimately the revolt ended in no change
llewellyn was executed and wales would
thereafter remain
firmly under english rule so what did
the conquest mean for england it secured
the western border gave
england a slightly larger taxable
population and also access to welshman
for armies importantly welsh bowman
whose role in the wars to come would be
vitally important
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching there is a list
of books in the description if you'd
like to know more
you